well this didn't age well over the last
few weeks sharp eyed fans have taken the
online forums to point out that on the
recent 4k release of Toy Story 2 one of
the fake bloopers featured during the
closing credits was conspicuously Missy
one which doesn't play so great in the
meat 2 era Pixar's films have a long and
storied history of including fake
bloopers or outtakes during their
credits and the critically acclaimed
1999 sequel to Toy Story was no
exception the gag in question involves
the villainous old prospector stinky
Pete who is caught having a questionable
chat with the Barbie twins by woody
while supposedly unaware that the
cameras are still rolling you know I'm
sure I could get you a part in Toy Story
3 I'm sorry I thought we back up oh all
I hate girls lovely talking with you
in retrospect it's pretty amazing that
this so-called blooper made it into Toy
Story 2 at all even as far back as 20
years ago but in the context of the
modern era a time when such former
Hollywood luminaries as Harvey Weinstein
Bryan Singer and louis c.k have all been
thoroughly disgraced in the wake of
numerous allegations of impropriety the
joke lands with nothing less than an
absolute thud for that matter Pixar and
the Toy Story franchise have not been
unaffected by the shift in perception
toward harassment in recent years John
Lasseter who co-founded Pixar and wrote
and directed the first two Toy Story
movies took a leave of absence from the
company in 2017 after admitting to
so-called missteps with female employees
according to The Hollywood Reporter
these allegedly included grabbing
kissing and making comments about
physical attributes and in mid 2018 it
was announced that Lasseter would be
leaving Pixar permanently you are a sad
strange little man and you have my pity
farewell
why Lasseter is officially no more his
shadow still looms large over the
animation company he helped found and
it's pretty likely that Disney
executives are well aware that the
troubles he brought upon himself are
still very much ongoing earlier this
year he was hired to head up sky dance
animation which is getting ready to
field luck its first feature in 2021 in
the wake of his hiring Academy
award-winning actress Emma Thompson who
had been set to voice a role in the
flick dropped out in protest in light of
all this it's pretty easy to see why
Disney would be keen to quietly cut a
scene which featured a member of two
story twos cast in a distasteful casting
couch scenario with a couple of Barbie
dolls users on forums like Reddit and
blu-ray comm jumped all over the
omission although many were quick to
point out that the scene hasn't always
been included in all versions of the
film such as the DVD release which
included it as a special feature instead
in addition to the 4k blu-ray the scene
has also been wiped from all official
digital downloads but according to Yahoo
movies it's still featured on the
version of the film offered by UK
streaming service Disney life it seems
pretty clear that this is one instance
in which enacting a little censorship is
totally the right decision by Disney
Pixar films are family films and while
it's one thing to include a few more
sophisticated gags that the adults can
enjoy it's another thing entirely to
have one of the characters in your
charming kid's film come across as
nothing less than totally sleazy in
light of Lassiter's behavior it would
have been even more shocking had Disney
not chosen to pull the offending gag
fans can now enjoy Toy Story 2 as it was
originally intended a romping adventure
about inevitable mortality and fear of
abandonment fun check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]